were so fool Podcast with phillipe as
far as I Rodrigo Torres yeah men were so
fool chillin dog are you livin good bro
our sponsor of today's episode is away
first-class luggage and a coach price
they create a special objects that are
designed to be resilient resourceful and
essential to the way travel away uses
high-quality materials while offering a
much lower compared price to other
brands by cutting out the middleman and
selling directly to you bro these bags
I'll tell you right now and they sent me
one and the bag is made out of plastic
hard plastic a gorilla could stand on
top of it and wouldn't break I don't
know why would he stand on it buddy it
wouldn't break took it to the zoo tsa
approved combination lock and unlock 360
degree degree spinner wheels you think
it's just rolling you have to carry it
and just move around you can put your
leg on top of it and stretch out both
sizes of the carry-on are rare are are
able to charge our cell phones tablets
e-readers and anything else powered by
USB cord so the bag has a charging port
for USB so you could just sit there and
charge your phone or you could charge
people to charge their phone that's a
little when you brought with you app
right here Leo I'll carry with me the
whole time tight also men all of their
suit keys are strong and can impact
resistant were also being lightweight
our luggages come with a hundred day
trial to live with it or travel with it
etcetera
it's not for you [ __ ] we turn it back
you don't get your full refund no
problem my personal experience with this
bag is I like it man it fits perfect you
know like something that's irking you
I'm check your bag you're like hell no
man this bag fits
they see if it fits another thing if it
doesn't they check plus it also expands
so you can open it more
oh yeah also this bag by the way is
alleged travelling to China you probably
won't be able to travel was that charger
in the bag but they comes with up a
little screwdriver that perfectly you
could take out the battery or put in
your bag and you don't go on your way
don't have to worry about it and this
week we had yet we had the good fortune
because remember our flight got canceled
in Atlanta so we got those tickets that
were cancelled and we we used those
tickets from our flight with a flag a
cancer Atlanta yeah that one time we
flew flew Mike Epps
so TC we use that money to upgrade and
booyah first-class baby
we were ruling like kings on first class
do you want to go to sleep just to get
all the snacks I know about your eternal
ad stand out with snacks
yes a wet towel not a wet towel hell
yeah I'll even use the wet towel just
took it I got two blankets in my bag
yeah man I've passed out three movies
some that doctor your honor I thought I
kept looking back and I thought I say
now I'm coming in a bigger curtain I
used to smell the people a regular coach
like the only good we don't always bomb
flat first clap but when we do we do and
I had a vegan me on the way back honest
right now would you get the couscous it
was it was couscous with a cold slab of
teriyaki tofu how was it it was cold you
know what man I don't like raises on
anything bro but cookies and raisin
bread that's it or carrot cake I don't
know I don't want to [ __ ] raisins and
tamales I don't want to raise him a
burrito I especially don't want my
raisin or Spanish rice unless Islam then
I'll let you go let you know raising it
there
I don't mind cuz I poke them out you
don't like raising it oh yeah so as a
listener of the worst of food podcast
you can get $20 off a suitcase if you go
to a way travel calm and use the code
what's up ooh that
wh ATS up you pee and check out all over
the story all over as the listener of
the war so poop podcast you can get $20
off a suitcase if you go to away travel
calm and use the code
what's up at the checkout and that's all
one word what's up wh ATS you pee away
travel.com a w a y TR a B e l.com and
use the code what's up so go check out
the bags on a way travel.com and be sure
to use the code what's up fool I mean
what's up and check out and get a $20
off man that's $20 off that's it and
well drink oh what's up man thank you
for very much bro for standing in front
of the Sun and giving her that beautiful
eclipse welcome you didn't get to see
the whole of the black upper glass is
broken glasses
there we go if you were not wearing
these glasses you are probably gonna go
blind soon these were the real the real
deal Holyfield Eclipse pass it did you
with you yes I saw it was awesome dude
every glasses oh yeah man that would
have been the money to make man if you
would have had [ __ ] eclipses two
weeks ago before everybody and stash
them you could have sold about five
bucks each probably did people are
looking for a man
[ __ ] that are Welding masks that's that
was that my dad was a welder when I was
a kid and um and uh it was like a little
solar eclipse back then I don't know
what kind of clips and my dad made us
wear his welding helmet it's awesome
dude
so we were where the 3d glasses from the
movies sitting there looking like Darth
Vader yeah my so guess what bro I'm back
acting class oh hell yeah House yeah man
I went back to my real acting class know
the road real but I like this one I went
back to Debbie Debbie Deb she was uh she
played a knuckle
getting on that movie the the the deuce
Bigalow should be the knocker let the
girl that was on a date with him falling
asleep okay so I went back to her acting
class bro and I'm back bro oh yeah are
you fat I feel good I feel confident I
feel the next time am I gonna call back
that's what's up
I feel good bro so that's that Oh big
news man gonna shout out shot our big
shout out I don't know who you are or
what you do but when I find you I'm
gonna give you for free tickets VIP to
my comedy show anywhere I go free
t-shirts free merch I'm gonna give you
stickers I'm gonna be your hugs I'm
gonna let you sit on Rodrigo's lap
because you my friend put my Netflix
video page on your Facebook page and
that [ __ ] went viral
it's at four point seven now say eight
million really yeah I seen it yesterday
I started off on friend she put it up on
December of 2016 on and then I started
getting like least Italian or they seen
that people were hitting her up by eight
when you gonna come to San Antonio
were you gonna come to San Antonio all
of a sudden we're gonna come to Austin
we were gonna come here I was just there
we're gonna come here walking problem
here tonight okay and then um so Friday
night it hit 1 million yeah well I was
saying on Saturday was at 2.7 yeah so
Friday night I hit 1 million and then
when and then I shared it on Anna
Maria's page on Monday morning and was
that 4 million so now that share that 8
million views I got a call from Edmonton
Calgary Edmonton Calgary Alberta to go
ahead line over there hell yet at some
comedy club
we'll see what happens so that's badass
so that's been good good bro also uh my
knees getting better
Oh your knee yeah I don't know what
happened bro what'd you end up doing it
to it right now I started walking like a
guy that hurt now needs a vital part of
your resilience so imma do a lot of
stretching yeah really good
what's up fool who just came back from
your why
Key West concert Wisconsin how was that
it was awesome dude Milwaukee was a [ __ ]
dude crazy fools in Milwaukee huh
dude people wanted a party in Milwaukee
yeah man oh my god man
we were we were like over there man in
the front of the casino and man we
passed by the Harley Davidson place we
saw Adam Murray happy hell yeah
that guy's always happy huh born happy
oh they're a piranha told me bad
childhood was just everything happy now
this guy this guy if the if anybody
walks out - here we go man you were
funny you read a whole blog about it you
know what man I don't know where this
cab driver knew who I was
of course you knew he was bro you sure
your order Oberoi is here at Emory you
tour together we tour together so man we
did the theater man and man Milwaukee
people love to party oh yeah I did I was
handed cocaine cocaine the guy the guy
you know shoutout to you man thank you
very much if I would have found you bro
I woulda gave it back to you man and a I
don't party like that so that forgave me
like some good weed and inside I thought
it was like I thought it was like he's a
bunch of zigzags huh
but it was like a rock see my mother
getting watery boy it was a rock rose
here mostly water because I'm an addict
it was a rock and you know beer Oh
somebody give you a rock iiiiii gay I
gave like a no girl bro again and I when
I see my story broke because I wanted to
do that [ __ ] I got like that I
got the demo right
people said I have a demo one shoulder
and I got I ain't join the other
shoulder nah man I have no angel bro I'm
an enabler on one side and a demo on the
other side 30-knot so I don't know what
to do man so I go to a drink oh here
they wanted - I don't worry says I don't
worry boy hey thank you were like my
stepdad used to do cocaine yeah
man don't do that man so I flipped on a
toilet you know that and we got through
the first night man and man we had some
sushi oh yeah dude she was BOM but the
shows were crazy too right after each
other dude boom boom dog not theater
they're two shows I don't know what kind
of crowd is gonna be mad no the Midwest
you know what to expect it was mixed so
good I mean Latinos represented it there
was a brothers in the audience - yeah
man though some people there who showed
up to my show because they saw me with
my caps
yeah those ladies in the front huh so
that's what's up man any shorts coming
up uh just uh
Romano's Rome on Wednesdays oh I did a
show last night at the laughs back
Robbins days during years bro how was it
done it was good man it was like you
know man
who you run into old old comics now old
but you know comments he started off
with or you service you know why it's so
we like summer camp to me you know like
when crowd to keep in touch but you
never keep in touch you know that's
that's where guest is today bro oh hell
yeah old school old school growing and
only the one and only and sorry yes oh
man yeah so you're two comedians in a
long time right oh you did she was
podcast that's Joe Perez you caught him
Chiba the goat I don't stand for the
greater good of all time it just starts
for the gorge of our time GP yeah fresh
stories I did it on Monday night it's
hot in that show huh oh yeah yeah I
started it off though I got him a little
[ __ ] with the Louie that they're
completely shut out two new either 13
the lower so Bart Louis huh no I started
get hot in that room dawg alright let's
take another break it was cool though
ham side - getting his little engineer
that was here that one day Xavier that
was cool man the podcasts out oh really
what can they find it you can find it on
soundcloud under George Perez stories
and yeah we did it dude we started late
though just showed up at 9:30 probably
not record until 10:30
yeah party style and then these fools
wanted to go to the strip club after
Dawg get some more stories I was like
I got a Tapout get some more stories
well you know if we're gonna go up there
parties and shits gonna go down dog man
who story story should happen
organically
not premeditated you can't make up a
story like a bro it's cool there see
what happened we'll talk about so I did
the Laugh Factory with Tiffany Haddish
on a show Rubin poor guy Torry Jay
Larson for care now who else me who else
that's it that's it the Jay Larson bro I
remember I did the Montreal Comedy
Festival him that food looking at
William Shatner on the TV cuz I like
that the TV the laughing OH
Captain Kirk the Laugh Factory still
selling their $8 $10 world-famous chips
and salsa world-famous bro you have
those chips and salsa before dude
they're Tostitos bro around and the hot
sauce
it's [ __ ] about it's like cheap salsa
I'm not gonna put on the laughs Patti
but I just know that I I've thought of
those chips before no you always try to
go for like a little like the little egg
rolls or like a slice of pizza
they don't have none of that then after
that bro seafood is a huge star she
showed up um I went up last just good
times and then you know we're not
standing on staff waiting for the car I
saw George passed by a bro in a blue
truck oh really he said what's up fool
where am i t-shirt dog really how are ya
bro so an ass you gotta guess what I got
him for he'll be at the show this Sunday
and Thursday
so yesterday people the Brera improv is
sold out
I don't know how sold out it is today
but we added two shows fried one show on
Saturday
it'll be 11:45 p.m. and a second show
added to the Sunday show that'll start
at 9:30 okay
also jiggle I got you your Christmas
present right here early bro I got you
[ __ ] two tickets to the Raiders
your game in Los Angeles room Christmas
Eve ooh me on the grass help Ravi take
you New Year's Eve so I brought ya plan
you're late for your zebra you could
either break up or you could not go or
you could just scalp these [ __ ]
and make money Dom [ __ ] all that go to
the game alright let's do this right
[ __ ] yeah we're gonna bring up our guest
of cognized podcast I told you guys I
started stand-up comedy when a lot of
you guys were kids in high school some
of you guys were born barely when I
started doing stand-up comedy I was
doing comedy now 20 years and I was
doing comedy seven years successfully
the comedian because up until 2010 it
was the struggle and I start doing
stand-up comedy be going act when I came
out of rehab I don't know what I heard
in my life and I thought I talked about
this on all things this is not happening
on Comedy Central this guy came up to me
with a list what should I do with my
life know what you want to do what she
goes what do you want to be in life so I
wrote down five things one of them was
to be a comedian number two was to go to
Italy one day I'm like Olive Garden
number three was to live sober to live
sober and clean and number four and five
I forgot what I was four point nine no I
couldn't think of anything else so I
wanted to be a comedian and I started
doing stand-up I didn't know how to
become a comedian how so like anybody
else I want no no Google just was 1994
there was no Google I decided to go to
library and I told the librarian I'm
looking for books on comedy writing
stand-up comedy or anything that had to
do with stand-up comedy and back then
bro there was not that many books well
that's what I it was gene parade of
writing Steve Allen jokes and lamb
Rick's you know writing skills and um
and then I found a book called how to be
funny how to write funny and make it
funny there's a yellow book that the
Judy brown one
that's the one and Adam Murray about
that weekend okay then I looked up where
we're gonna be a comedian
I saw the alley weekly and they said
open mic open mic I don't know what that
was you know so I saw a place that was
close to my house you know like a place
that I'd have a car I was at a rehab I
had no money I was working AUP I was
working at you and ups a security guard
from 10 o'clock at night to 6:00 in the
morning
damn so I said oh so I can't I said this
before I said alright let's just do this
oil go to LA Weekly
I saw natural fudge on Melrose Avenue
open mic Monday and then I'll get there
I get there bro
and it's like a [ __ ] like a miniature
auditorium with classroom seats and and
um
and now church pews - damn and dusty ass
porno movie theater seats that were all
scratched up well some of them open some
of them didn't they were like chairs
stacked up for I don't know for what and
I saw I met the Muny twins I saw the
money - and I thought hilarious then it
was my turn bro I don't know what to do
so I went up on stage bro and I said um
I said these two guys there was a guy
there that they stand-up comedy but he
was trans like an Amish guy he goes wah
we were the first black Amish guy this
guy has no lights he has no checks he
has no electricity you know whatever is
I'm crowning him then I crown another
guy I thought a deep good
I don't know what bombing was then the
owner came up to me Johnny Roberts hey
kid you were amazing
we're shooting a television show next
week would you come on down goddamn just
like that my dad brought that I made it
dog I thought he will flow tonight's
show or something
you know cuz he was like the owner he
was wearing a suit he kept saying hair
everybody tried a nutburger cuz it was a
vegetarian please try nut nut burger and
then the he'll he'll put his wife's I'm
leanin Brenda
who look like she [ __ ] everybody in
the funny Allman Brothers bro like she's
to party back in a daze brother she to
be a groupie for [ __ ] out for through
the groupie for deep purple bro some ham
hardcore hippie lady wearing sandals bro
no bra tiny little little white booty
bro I tell you a funny story about her I
wasn't because anyway so I meant I long
I saw Alonzo Bodden there I don't know
his name back there but I know he was
there
Jamie Kennedy and I think Freddy solo
later on Reuben Quintana my son um and I
thought these food were already famous
wrong they were so funny because they
had Joel I know Joel I thought I had
jokes and then he in comes in this big
fat fool bro
I think he's Jewish you know and
intimate I mean I never met Jewish
people before I thought their other
choice people were for one for TV you
know the water throwing rocks at the
Palestinians you know yeah Israel at all
he goes up there bro and he does
appeared about his neighborhood bro
everybody was doing regular jokes like
they had jokes this guy came in actually
talking about life the the what their
you know like you know like so could be
you know like me now it's open to talk
about your life before I was like keep
running jokes just care was ahead of
time bro for me he was just talking
about what was going on in neighborhood
right so this food and he goes I live in
a neighborhood where every player plays
the same song well every week the same
song every [ __ ] week every [ __ ]
singing the same song and this B song is
I need you so I thought that was
hilarious and then I run our guest today
man is the comedian I met that day there
was L bird man ladies and gentleman and
he's been to all Quixote's
man that was a Joey's to do about the
baby
Oh the bay the baby cry yeah that yeah
man that into the ground what would you
call me a Jewish faith Oh what is that
close yeah mrs. fat fool man if that
fool was like I thought like a Spanish
word of Favell which means fat fool yeah
that's what that meant this fat fool bro
he wouldn't up that man and then he
didn't give a [ __ ] man
he'll making fun of the older [ __ ]
chick and at that okay he says guys
[ __ ] funny
and then I'm after him was even crazier
Jewish guy and he start making fun of
the older look at your [ __ ] brother
you're [ __ ] flat tits Wow Brian
Holtzman Holtzman and it was time to
give them the light
[ __ ] yeah get off [ __ ] like that dude
and I'm like [ __ ] man was crazy over
there trying to get everybody by that
[ __ ] [ __ ] yet nutburger
oh yeah wow man this so manner I left
him and learn a lot bro just that one
night I saw these different styles that
I saw this guy was a [ __ ] real comedy
but ma'am Brian was like insane bro you
started with that guy huh yeah I start
with Brian we're still good friends
he has dual open mics together back
there yeah a lot of a lot of open mics
and then he's at the Comedy Store in a
Laugh Factory
he's doing great so what did you start
off at I started off with the natural
fudge that was the place I started off
in and just doing unlike you I knew it
open mics were you know that's what I
did I saw open mic not plural bro so
only would there was a week
so when Johnny Reilly was i lying about
Johnny Roberts no no no but I I knew
Brenda better yeah and she was she was a
trip
yeah I remember Rob when Brett when
Johnny passed away yeah yeah Johnny
passed away and it was a comedy store
okay and I'm there all high and Jamie
Kennedy comes up to me cuz Jimmy came
they started there to gets all neatly
parroting and Jamie Kennedy was a four
we pay you know remember Johnny from the
black surfers yeah man he passed away
oh I [ __ ] up you should go over there
man they're all having like a little
get-together at the natural fudge so I
go there right I go there and they're
like I see Brenda and she getting a big
hug all Felipe I always loved you cuz
she was the first woman I've told me
about that a fact you Latino night oh
really
cuz they hit her up and then she said
Felipa do you do any Spanish comedy no
they're looking for Latinos for the
Latino night The Laugh Factory maybe the
message wasn't sent right me no maybe
she thought it was all Spanish but it
was all English at the time Wow going to
the laugh at you almost five years I
didn't go to be five years to go over
there you say like Johnny hooked you up
with that right yeah Johnny Sanchez
later on told me when I met him at the
Waldos but I'm so I'm off track I'm
going back to Brenda so I'm at the
natural Pharrell and I and I give Brenda
a hug she is a weeping bro we beaten so
then I'm we're all hanging out with the
comedian's then I look over at her and
she's making out with a Mexican drug
like making out bro like a song that got
soldier bro that guy's not even in the
ground yet bro they must have had an
open relation to the kissing abroad like
suck kissing her tears though there well
yeah I guess she's gonna be okay he's
gonna be okay she reminded me of like a
Lily Tomlin character yeah she kind of
looked like a Lily Tomlin character so
that the national funds worked like this
band punk band and then they'll get off
and the comedian will go up that was a
Monday night that I remember so you
started off you're telling us you're
sober right you have a podcast I have a
podcast called sober man podcast please
Lily you're sober I'm sober it'll be
fine nothing no no pot and III for the
last two years I thought about listen I
love pot I'd still love the smell of it
it's just but the thing is for me I'm
such an addict I just afraid that if I
did it that's all I would do how long
you been sober
whoo
29 years you know how when I met you I
was sober when I met you oh like I was
like going I was like oh um I fell off
the wagon on my 11th year but when I met
you I was like going on four years sober
and I was to going to meetings so oh
yeah oh really
y'all going to any okay so I started out
in CA and and then went to a miracle
Keene howl okay powder I got into crack
crack came into vogue at that time I
only tried it once and at that point I
was I didn't need any more monkeys on my
back you know I just like you know and I
got sober and I've been sober ever since
so though I have dreams where I'm not
sober me too
I still have true I have dreams where
I'm like going oh I've been I've been
bullshitting people all these years and
then it takes me a while I wake up and
go I'm sober then a normal gene for an
addict yeah that is like worst story has
a shell-shocked yeah yeah it's it's
normal he's like a being shell-shocked
from living a bad life yeah cuz I have
dreams sometimes there are I do like I
drink I started off as I get drunk but
then I'm all cracked out again you know
doing sober and then like I'm so ashamed
in my dream that I decide not to go home
at all oh that happens to me like seemed
they said not to go home
then a real like something in my dream
decides that oh it's only a dream then I
wake up I get scared
my dreams are mostly about pot oh yeah a
lot of weed yeah why don't we and you
know these days is there's weed stories
they didn't have that back in my day
weeds everywhere it's everywhere and
it's strong how did you get into cocaine
you see you in a pile I went through a
cocaine open-mike mica started snorting
for free now um how did I get into it
there was a pocket it's a good club
there's a pot dealer I was dealing with
and he had some coke here in Hollywood
yeah in Hollywood yeah you're from
Hollywood not from northern New Jersey
northern New Jersey Paterson where that
like near that where the Sopranos was
was took place yeah you know so I like
to claim claim Sopranos so I I just was
smoking a lot of weed and it's
pot dealer I knew had some coke and I
tried it and it was just like whoo it
was really good and I remember thinking
oh I gotta be careful I was so careful
that I went five years straight you know
and he just started I just started
hitting him up and I inherited like
$3,000 gonna my grandmother died $3
3,000 and this is like 85 and so I just
I just blew through all that you know
with little grams and half grams and
were you in Jersey doing that rela
this is La well you're doing open
camellia no no no I was playing music in
those days I had a band what's the name
of the band the band was called
imitation life and we had a little bit
of so we had some success on or we were
on a couple record labels we were like
kind of known in Europe and college
radio you know so we had a couple
records in it you sang I was just
believe it or not is the elite singer
rhythm guitarist chief songwriter and
you can't you know you said song right
and he's like say oh that fat fool came
in but that I got so gained so much
weight in sobriety because food is the
is the original drug you know you get
sober and now I'm trying to I've been
out like a five weeks of a ketogenic
diet just trying to like fricking and
get an older man I don't wanna how'd you
stop I mean you're the meetings right
away to do to rehab what what was your I
didn't know I didn't have own bad legs
would you'd spin at that time wicked did
you spend a lot of days a week
oh actually are you all night saying
what the movies to the wing doing this
[ __ ] no more than a day but I mean I
spent many nights where I you know
you're here you're looking at the window
and and the the birds are chirping and
then somebody throws a newspaper against
the building and you go what the hell
was that you know it scares the hell I
did here's one thing I used to do I
could I used to drink beer with Michael
Caine so if I ran out of beer say it's
like four o'clock in the morning I'd be
waiting until the supermarket would be
legal to buy buy coke
I mean buy buy beer so I would go there
about 5:30 5:30 and pretend to shop you
know just pretend to shop and so that
six o'clock I could buy a six-pack go
home and just pound the beer so I could
frickin go to sleep you know
and I've done that lots of time man
aroused and I will get there and man
it's it's it's kind of like sad hug when
you don't think about it at a time but -
you're sober up then the next day that
up everybody's going wrong about their
lives
and you're there to hide the look of
disgust on your ass oh yeah it sucks
I'm pretending I just got off from work
yeah you know I'm pretending yeah I just
got off work here just you know wanna go
home because I work the night shift you
know I mean what her eyes are all beamed
up oh yeah what do you do yeah my arc
welder
uh also if I ran out of say if I ran out
of coke see the last two years of doing
it I I was scoring exclusively off the
streets so yeah so streets the streets I
know cuz in Hollywood I was all over
that area that all that area you have a
specific dealer or nothing before or
what I did it was that guy who got the
pot dealer but he stood me up one time
and I got pissed off you know and I said
he's the hell with that I'm going
through the streets you know what's up
with the streets different people
pow yep it was all powder you get burned
a lot would you buy that Hollywood
Valley you know no no in in Hollywood
the different there were different play
I could take you on a tour I could take
you to sit in certain places and go I
usually buy coke there but there was a
park on Vermont by MacArthur Park
no I didn't well not MacArthur Park for
mine it's a little Park Chateau Park Oh
Chateau d'eau Chateau Lane chatelaine
in back in there now Chateau is hardcore
I was going there I am chateau the play
you don't want to go there you know I
did one time I was such an idiot I one
time Chateau part I didn't have anything
that the guy had they had I would find
some coke and a guy didn't have I didn't
have anything to put it in like he just
had a baggie so I was gonna put it on a
tissue we went into work into the men's
room and I was gonna put on a tissue and
they these guys took care of me they go
no no they they found a thing and they
guy took out a big knife and put the
coke I mean we think could have just
frickin just gave me yeah just go to me
but I do anything for my coke so wow so
much at Oak Park so you minimize shots
Hellenes chateau no no I just knew
somehow I don't remember how I knew that
you could go there how did you know
old man like it's funny how how a drug
addict works burrow like sober in a
sound mind
oh I remember looking for crack over
there by MacArthur Park 18th Street
right there was by the ms-13 gangs
hanging out at cuz I knew what the gang
were and I'm just driving my car I'll
pick up a [ __ ] crackhead it's listen
man you want 20 bucks yeah get in my
[ __ ] car and help me find it [ __ ]
crack right now and you'll give me the
[ __ ] 20 bucks so I haven't driving
around I think well you know a guy well
over here what time to come to the car
see man all this takes a lot of bars bro
I could never do this [ __ ] sober
no never late at night out sobered
paranoid thinking about I can't go out
at that night I can't go out and do that
again but I [ __ ] still do it again I
would hear gunshots
and I go oh time to go out you know I
like I wouldn't I wouldn't even stop me
I go I gotta go I gotta go because I
gotta go
you know I'd be standing in in Hall and
like I'd go to like these ghetto
hallways and be waiting somebody would
be going knocking on the door the dealer
I'd be waiting with I gave him 50 bucks
I'm getting chills thinking about it now
man so how can I get me some coke right
now how did how did you how did you know
to glitter shots for lanes I don't
remember I don't remember that I don't
know I just lived in that area and there
was like different like places that I
would get it from you just seen the
activity and people slanging and stuff
like that and go up to him right yeah
the whole park was just was just people
dealing and people scoring you know how
I never got arrested or you know is
amazing that's I find that amazing how I
never got arrested
I never one time I was waiting for a guy
this is unbearably by Western the street
next to where like Oxford or whatever
it's called and I'm in a car that guy
give the guy money I'm waiting outside
this building and his car pulls up and
flashes his beams and I just go alright
I guess I'll just go and was a freaking
was a black and white man police office
five oh man and what I do I went around
the block I went to the parking lot shut
the lights waited for the guy picked him
up because nothing was going to get in
the way
don't care and I didn't you know was
amazing Wow
you ever get ripped off with fake stuff
yeah a high school kid I'm so ashamed in
his high school kid okay at Chateau Park
I gave him the money and he got he got
me some either didn't give it to me or
he got me something that wasn't coke and
the next time I saw him I punched like
I'm a freaking man at this point I this
kid is under 18 I punched him in the
chest
and then I go what the hell am i doing
man I mean you know he got he got all he
got all defensive you know I had let it
go of course you know you never got
burned fool with any weak [ __ ] or
anything that you notice it was kind of
cut too much oh yeah listen it didn't
matter after a while you just snorting
like [ __ ] yeah a chalk man it was if
it's white and it's powdery yeah you
just don't you just don't care I mean
when I first started when I got hooked
on it I was just like good [ __ ] right
was the great [ __ ] this guy was actually
smuggled it in from like Colombia or
something like that
so I thought that that you know but then
as time went on you're chasing you're
just chasing that forever yeah cuz I'm
that's how doesn't get you man like I
remember one there every time I've done
coke again that line were the best one
then after that like chasing the dragon
bro oh yeah the first line a million
bucks second a half and by the end of
the night you're just like you're just
you broken and then I remember one time
bro I was I was hanging out with some
chick and I kept doing this coke right
and I remember kept going to the
bathroom and [ __ ] had diarrhea bro
over and over bro I wasn't squeaky but I
diarrhea all day that happened a lot to
you to what happened to me go cuz they
would cut it with baby laxative but that
reminds me I had a friend that lived in
that neighborhood either these brothers
and you ever had that kid people would
would have gun they would think they'd
get their guns out we do a couple lines
and then he'd take his gun down go I'm
just gonna walk around the block around
the block to make sure everything's cool
like a freakin gun for that goddamn dude
yeah hey do you think part of the
addiction too is like the high from the
mission to those core I think it's part
of it I think here's what I think I
think addiction is your previous I think
it's a predisposition
chin like I think I'm genetically
predisposed and then your upbringing you
know if you have like kind of like
family whatever issues your father
knuckle holiday or your mom no but they
were there kind of they had their issues
you know they were mean you right rage
you're hot now they didn't beat me they
verbally I'll be verbally abusive you
know double messages mixed messages why
I love you Amy I don't know why do I
leave me some drugs you try smoking pot
young yeah you know like teens yeah 13
no not that not that young you started
young I've been around it since I was
young but I didn't try it I was 18 I
went from smoking pot at 19 to going
smoking crack by the time I was 21
that's how long it took Wow see I only
smoke crack once and that was towards
the end of my coke run and it was about
around 87 88 and I just I thought I
thought you know I don't need any more
problems here did you do the did you
party was is coat by yourself or you
have friends you were I had four ends
but I did a lot of it by myself a lot of
it was just to you know isolate get the
beer pull the curtains and let's go to
town folks and what do you think made
you not do coke with all these comics
then it was not a comic doing coke I
didn't know that I didn't do it I didn't
know they were doing so I started doing
it I didn't I guess I didn't come in
contact with that too much yeah too much
with the comedian's you know yeah when
you're a comedian man you pretty much
could avoid that stuff if you don't do
it
but once you start doing it you find out
who's doing everything is crazy people
come out of the closet yeah man that's
it that's the word and cokes the worst
man it's though it's the stupidest drug
by the time you start doing comedy you
were already done with cocaine and
drinking I was done with yeah I was
playing music and then about a year and
a half into my sobriety I started comedy
and I quit I stopped my band and yeah so
been sober ever since unless those
dreams I have you know was the slip
dreams I remember I'm when used to go to
that room in Montebello gotham's yeah
gotham's
yeah God when he was there okay and when
he was going there I think it was a
different host it was a singer like a
little Asian dude yeah he was a real
original
yeah he's Oscar here bro yeah yeah who's
that it was Ron Williams what was it all
wrong Williams yeah he could have some
run William but with Filipino brother
his stage name and their contacts are
pretty boy yeah he how did you know how
did this guy start comedy there cuz you
know I'm we run we ran there foo out
know Jeff Garcia he got it after him
Jeff Garcia somehow mostly way in there
and took the room from him oh no I know
if he muscled his way I wasn't even
gonna say that but Jeff had the room
after run William lost him somehow right
and then um the hole then then I'm Jeff
Garcia got into a big fight if you know
it's funny um when Jeff Garcia lost a
room he lost it because he got into a
fight or something happened I wants a
fight I don't know what happened but
something happened on Sunday it was gay
night mm-hmm so he locked he like he got
the roof I'm a gay guy and then last
year a gay night gonna give a room to
Willie Barcena Oh Willie had it and then
after I booked that room for ten years
after that I wish I would have known I
didn't know what and um and I remember
you had a joke that killed me when you
were there because you know there's a
sports bar and they were watching a
Dodger Stadium
they were watching a Dodger game and
then you said I'm wow nobody pay
attention to me everybody watch the
Dodger game it's okay right now at
Dodger Stadium they're watching me on
diamond vision this guy you got a great
memory what was what was up you being
like as it was as a as a comedian one of
the places you said man it's your worst
bomb if you ever had a bomb oh we all
have had bombs my worst bomb was when I
first started did you know a comedian
named Peter Petoskey this is before you
beautiful he was um he wasn't part of
the open mikes he was already doing the
you know the profession he was like an
acrobat he could do these these he would
flip
fall down and physical stuff he I he
kind of took me under his wing and we
went to a college and I was supposed to
split the opening spot 20 minutes with
his wife
tenènte I could barely do 10 at that
point so we're supposed to do split that
tenant in the night right before we go
to decides not to come he says you're
doing 20 stretch you know what that's
like you know when you first start you
know so I got up there and I was just a
tanked and to the point where they were
doing it was a packed film ecologies
they were doing that that bombing
sounded I was in a documentary called oh
I'm dying up here I'm laughing dying
yeah I was on a plane in a words having
a bar bombing man and how did the
bombing feel at you oh gee go ah [ __ ]
take us back to last night it is fun it
[ __ ] you you can't you can't really do
anything it does after unless you can
flip it around dog and that's very rare
in males really shitty dude the the
hardest bunk I get now like it's not
like it's not the bombing that I kind of
knowledge member is gonna notice but it
kind of bombed me that I know personally
and it in my head I know that I'm stuck
somewhere you know and I can't get out
of it and I can't go back to the
material somehow because my mind is to
focus on his [ __ ] bad bombing I'm
getting it right I had a thing what's
the belly room the county store was like
a like some kind of african-american
night and I wouldn't even call this a
bomb because I went up there a Tuesday
it wasn't Fat Tuesday because it was
before Fat Tuesday without a Monday
night yeah the Monday night was upstairs
and yeah yeah like these guys in the
front were just they wouldn't let me say
anything I said I want to do it and they
just started yelling at me and yelling
at me and I just walked out that side
door and so I mean I guess that is a
bomb right you know I couldn't okay so I
tell you I started when I met up I made
a lot of people that the Communists at
our natural fires like free
SoDo yeah Freddie was my good friend
little driving that post office truck
remember oh yeah Freddie so don't ever
[ __ ] post office truck no Jeep a
little cheaper but ever hey was like an
old post post man I got a Freddie and I
became good friends and I'm a little bit
of shame this meet when Freddie first
started
me and Jamie Kennedy were really really
tight and we were friends with Freddie
Freddie was so bad in the beginning I
used to hang out with you guys I'd you
go eat with you guys had norms before
there was uh oh yeah before it was album
wasn't it call now Mel's Diner
oh well Ben Franks and Frank's yeah
before you norm before us Mel's Diner it
was Ben Franks and Frank on Sunset I
could test it huh it was a it was a real
old-school coffee shop it was great 24
hours and III got to unfortunately to go
with you guys maybe a couple of times
and fortunate I was fortunate you know
yes we we black we sanctioned it I
tagged along bro and I ate with Jamie
Kennedy Freddie sólo al and scintilla be
nothing so if you live in Dillon I just
did a gig with her yeah man and then we
were all young comics bro and then of
course Jamie came they had no money I
think you were living in his car I have
no money no money bro he was like that
was before he wrote that letter for that
I think after that he went to London to
do comedy to do English act you know
before no after he he went to London for
this so funny what a memory he went to
London to study at a Shakespeare yeah
and then he did that for the summer and
then he came back I was what he did is
he got a couple of self-help books
Think and Grow Rich and something else
who did Jamie did I didn't open mike at
a book set up like a coffeehouse they
were used copies and these books changed
his life and I saw him go from here
Anika's he applied it he went from being
completely broke within a few months
just getting commercials and then he
started getting agents and management of
GB MTV TV movies and all that kind of
stuff he killed him Jamie blew up the
same time that song from beg came out
my loser baby right right I'm gonna go
buy the whole skating [ __ ] you know it's
all part of that little part of that mix
remember he did it guess he won every
bright before you hit the last factory
when he had his FX show when he was
barely starting they hit that cool
little part in this scary movie scary
movie I know that was a scream scream
yes that's where that's what put him put
him over here scream yeah but we're all
hanging out bro yeah that's crazy dude
it was called what was called the
independent Frank's Ben Franks and I
think it was better then than it is now
as Mel's Diner old-school hah fool it
was yeah yeah old-school American
American holes used to right right for
comedians Jim Kennedy no I mean I hope
that not really you know well actually
that take that back I did write on his
special I mean I thought you're talking
about like a back in the early bills IRA
helped him write on his special one of
his specials and then um after that the
whole natural first thing was done
another room popped out and this lady
actually goes to my shows when I'm gonna
pass Oh dawn Oh dawn she's my friend on
Facebook yes III every time I go pass
old dawn and her husband go to my show
Chris right Chris they showed up with
that big RV yeah bro do you remember
Chris's dad yeah he's to see you shall
learn I said I used to make so much fun
of him because he is so much reverb you
were so funny when you to make fun of
anybody bro bro before made fun of
people bro that you didn't do they gonna
make fun of Bro like oh like the owners
and then dawn the blonde lady had a
father or a Chris father and he was that
car he was a crooner bro crooner with a
lot of echo rattle reverb on his mic
yeah and um he um when they were looking
for a song to be the official song of
Los Angeles Hey Don's a father Chris his
father he rolled his own Ali song and
turned it in of course they didn't take
it but he sang in every show there's
funny there was remember there was a guy
there I don't know what he did but he
had a he was older guy a friend of
theirs really bad toupee her rendus
toupee and I was gonna make fun of him
but I was warned against it like he was
old-school doji you know they said do
not make fun of that guy this is like
okay but then why dude no no he liked
you oh yeah that's funny man so you do
wow those right well the Waldos was in
the hotel
Hollywood and Highland Highland Sunday
nights Sunday nights he knows the
friggin days within the time no no I
would only do comedy bro on that was
what after natural fudge I had to laugh
at you then I had Waldo's and then I'm
mad maybe we should do the arm the
[ __ ] um was chewy from the Comedy
Store he to bring out that big jar which
to write our name on it
Oh hot look oh yeah ooh yeah hot look at
the Comedy Store
I knew chewy from a place called the LA
cabaret and they might have been closed
before
damn oh that was in Encino yeah you did
the alley cabaret yeah was the original
owners yeah well you going there when it
was hot or there was dead no no it was
already gone and I once told the owner
on the phone and go [ __ ] himself and I
forget what happened he was such an
[ __ ] to me you can swear in this
thing right because I usually I usually
don't swear but I told him to go [ __ ]
himself and then I felt so bad as a
sober I had to make making amends to him
so I call him back and I said listen his
name was Ray I said ray I'm calling to
apologize for for what I said to you I
don't want to play your club I'm not
saying that because I want to play at
your club just you know you're not gonna
play it anyway oh yeah [ __ ] you were so
fool Oh Riley the gentlemen we have our
second sponsor it's called bomb fell do
you hate going shopping for clothes are
you like me and never have time to go
shopping or maybe don't know what to
wear or how to put an outfit together
and that's what a lot of you
[ __ ] like seeing you guys
there's an easier and better way to shop
for clothing ok maybe you don't know
what to wear or how to put an outfit
together there is an easier better way
to shop for clothing bomb fell there
this cool new service that I
904 because I hate clothes shopping I
have never home to go shopping and I
want to have someone else pick things
out for me that I might like cuz usually
man when I pick up my clothes I like it
at the store but then when I get home I
[ __ ] hate it bro you only pay for the
clothes you keep it's called bomb fell
be OMB f e ll bomb fell you sign up put
in your measurements and style choices
what kind of clothes you like casual
preppy etc these are actual clothes but
not like when you buy an extra-large and
it's too tight or too loose don't send
your measuring tape to measure your
chest and your length and everything or
tailor self yeah and they pick up the
colors for you man the right colors a
match to match bro it's like having a
personal dresser all the time so I got a
little outfit a little outfit you have
outfits bro matching stuff no more you
know tennis shoes and shorts no L just
kidding no more sweats like you and I
bro no matching sweats
least I got it too right no all right
there's no she's didn't get it was I not
supposed to wear shorts for this no just
kidding no like you know these people
pick at your clothes you choose how many
things you want to see pants shirt
etcetera they have stylist bro pick out
an outfit that they send you an email
with the clothes and you can say whether
you like them or not and if you do liked
it like it they send it to your house
and you have seven days to try them on
where you can wear these to church to a
house party if you don't like it send it
back you know and then keep them or
stand them back saying you don't like
them and they won't charge you they only
charge you for for like once you keep
the clothes anyways they stand with two
t-shirts and a pair of pants the shirts
were tied bro I don't know who where it
is extra large it was tie-dye bro he
could see all my my nipples were hard
everything is everything my rear
I still children 2x you know that was my
bad my bad like bow from a fault but I
was like able to send it back and I'll
see what they choose for me next month
the pants bro the past fall girl bro
they were perfect
you know man I kept the [ __ ] pants
they were perfect you know they felt I
felt I put it on flannel yeah it just
felt comfortable like I could take a nap
at least I could go on a coke binge and
pass out Hey no brother Saab they
thought I sweat right there denim that's
cool
love the pants they're high quality and
super soft and nothing is greater than
getting home and seeing a hand pink
outfit sitting on your porch ready for
you to wear and you didn't have to do
anything as a listener of the word so
full podcast you can get $25 off your
first purchase or go to barn fail calm
slash whoop bond felt calm slash wolf
and that w UF / w UF that's bomb fell
dot-com /w you have bo mb f e ll do t co
m / w you have to get $25 off your first
purchase bomb fell open and close bomb
fell open and close so what sort of G go
back I see you something you just go you
know something you delay [ __ ] but most
the time you look good bro is your self
word yeah your mom just about just but
man those outfits oh my god tell me that
I went clothes shopping with my mom one
time out of the reader comedian you know
we haven't hang out and she wants to go
buy me clothes full I went ahead her bro
I thought I wanted to cry at the
bullshitty Barbies go
bump me a long-sleeve striped shirt like
long-sleeve striped shirt with matching
shorts bro unless she got me a red
t-shirt with a matching shorts bro
I mean when I'm gonna [ __ ] rugby team
I like she dresses you I should attend
no ain't broke don't worry do don't go
to mom fail calm what's up fool with you
wait was al Burman bully I did that it
watch that [ __ ] gonna do a little
what's up fool myself so you were like
oh you were hanging out with Freddie
solar a long time you're the longest
commercials in this podcast ain't
nothing right now oh yeah yeah
Freddie Soto and I yes we were we were
good buddies and we're tight super tight
but what I wanted I was talking about
before I'm a little bit of a ashamed of
and I talked about this in his
documentary that I think is why put
together Jamie and I used to make fun of
him behind his back because he was so
bad and he was terrible he was but then
we got with him and I they cut out to a
character's yeah and then fast forward
to like a few years later I was at the
Laugh Factory when I was working with
Jamie and I saw Freddie and he became a
great great community I saw him about a
year before he he passed and him and I
got robbed together what we got robbed
in the neighborhood of Melrose Normandy
there who know bad back there yeah he
drove me home one night and I had the
door open we were just chatting after
it's like a Mike and all of a sudden
this little chilly tow comes by with a
Curt kerchief on his face a handkerchief
a bandana welcome red or blue I forget
what color was I almost started laughing
because I thought it was a joke is he
look so funny but then I saw the gun
right and then he said you know he put
the gun on me then another guy came
around put the kind of Freddie and two
more other guys came with with no with
no guns
they only had one bandanna for one for
four guys you know one banana so they
went in your pockets or what they
I had $4 they took my comedy notebook oh
my god
in my bat aback they took my bag that
was the only thing I was that pissed and
they took my little tape recorder and we
sent those little cassette recorders
they took that and I drove around the
neighborhood afterwards trying to to
find it and the cops came we call the
cops in any of course they put us up
against the wall right away yeah and
check this out what do you think wasn't
Zeebo Freddy Freddy they took a lot he
had a lot of stuff he had a nice coat he
had something took his jacket I think
they had he had some jewelry he had a
lot of stuff yeah yeah more than Rocchi
yeah a lot more stuff than I did I have
I swear I had $4 a comedy notebook I
started doing bits like if you see some
cholos doing my act let me know must
have been pissed again Shaitaan or the
golden jacket me what they just showed
know their neighborhood I don't know
they probably random people I think they
were robbing random people and then when
they did there was a couple in the car
in front of us that were kind of like
making out and they went to rob them
well so we were we had a wait until they
got done robbing them you know before we
could leave and they had a [ __ ] up car
that was puttering down the street and
they were like giggling like kids you
know damn yeah that gun says it all
though huh the other gun says it all not
one that lets Jill relate and there
wasn't any minute that any second that
moment it's time to take these guys o
become a hero dad I just say I got real
I get real relaxed in situations like
that one lay down on this couch perfect
let me just enjoy the enjoy the robbery
let me just enjoy it fellas I did it I'm
Brian Holtzman get carjacked oh my god
you already did
little traveler convertible because I
was when that happened I was thinking
wow all my friends were from out of town
okay carjacked in LA and robbed he got
carjacked I think somewhere in Echo Park
er yeah he was driving with somebody and
I don't remember what
happen but they got carjacked yeah Wow
there's anything that that ever happens
you again in our lane well one time I
was driving home and it was really late
maybe two or three in the morning and
again there's a car of you know whatever
to cholo guys and back in me just me in
front and a red light them and back
about four of them and all of a sudden
one of them sticks a gun out and starts
shooting into the air yeah and I would
just like again I get really relaxed so
there's nothing I can do there's nothing
I can do just just drive and I just made
a right and they kept going they just
you know whenever behind you or spotted
you they were behind me but they III
made a right and they went that way
oh yeah they left me alone they figure
maybe they maybe they was with the guys
got me you know it man it's better
[ __ ] car you had bro your car was like
that kind of color people will take to
go do a drive-by well the end of long
played with a long car was a big the
hooptie bro we right yeah leaked leaked
all the major fluids you know the oil
homie you know when a fish don't we know
have fun in the the homies they rob you
bro and I whenever was pulled me over
they were collected a homie you I'm
gonna fix those dents bro I work for I
I'm my body build item I bought oh body
guy a Bronco pick those dents was that
like gypsy guys like no they were
Mexican my April I had a gypsy guy one
time yell at me in the valley with this
big hook T he yelled across traffic get
that piece of [ __ ] off of the road is he
bustin my balls and he just like he was
serious you know you never even came
over to see he could fix it he just
wanted it off the snow off the streets
wow what do you most of the time what do
you do you still write yeah I'm getting
actually I took a long time off from
stand-up and I'm kind of trying to get
back into it now I am getting back into
it now doing my podcast and I got a
regular regular part-time gig I do which
is the dream come true you know yeah no
not really
it's okay I make when did you start your
particular the podcast you by yourself
or yes it's just me by myself telling
stories in their you know comedic ly
bent but there's you know it's me doing
it in my house alone and it's about 30
minutes and it's about me seeing the
world through my sober eyes a lot of it
about food food my food problems you
know yeah yeah just me dealing with when
I win that when I came out of rehab I I
picked up by different addictions you
know before I fell off the wagon I don't
know if you refer out the wagon but um
no I picked up gambling I know the
hardcore gamer Oh gambling really yeah
you're like gambling they say gambling a
cocaine affects the same part of the
brain it does yeah synapse or what cuz I
when you're like when you're like after
you lose all your money your paycheck or
whatever you have you just feel the same
depressed and sad it's weird what was
your what was your game blackjack
anything blackjack slot machines
everything
where'd you go to Vegas no I went to uh
I went through Vegas like like long
story short man I went through my for my
father
I had my dad I never talked about it but
I had my father's money like I was
holding it for him again he was hiding
it from my mom you know you know you
know beans guy he's being shady you know
and um you know at first I borrow
someone a little little by little I
borrow some of the money to buy an
outfit because Willie Barcena I was
gonna be on tonight's show and then I
wanna know like [ __ ] right this will boy
bagging on me cuz I was with all I would
only wear like a jeans and tennis shoes
and a white t-shirt
you know that's how I dress or I would
dress with my cargo shorts you know or a
t-shirt hey are you [ __ ] truth like a
[ __ ] like a loser bro like somebody
what clean his ass dog and somebody to
have a dirty house bro hey bro someone
right clean his ass I have bro I have
all those things dawg so this is the
dress this is a red dress bro you chuck
it
that's a soil as a pocket so I want to
Melrose and about a nice jacket bro that
[ __ ] wasn't all
only $5 you know but it wasn't my money
so I used that money then I bought a
badass pants I like a [ __ ] bad-ass
shirt bro but my shirt was [ __ ] good
shirt bro the good shirt yourself a
little outfit so I got a little outfit
and then a little by little bro like I
went through all that money bro and this
was your dad's money yeah I would throw
that money and in my dad would see me
every week to ask for money and I will
give it to him it was like we're on a
lot of money bro like a lot of money
then I didn't have and um let me tell
you man I felt just like an addict when
he came up to me man like man he came up
to mean he said um he wanted the money
and we were we were like in at the
tropical cafe bro and um I had to come
clean bro
they were doing them more money and I
don't know how we're gonna do it you
know like and then I said I'm [ __ ] it's
so hard to say now and I just told him
that um I let it to a gambling problem
dad and hmm and I've went through all of
it and it's all gone I mean there's
nothing I don't know what to tell you
but um there's only like six hundred
dollars left eight hundred at least but
that's all it's all gone you know I want
to tell you I'm sorry what do you say
now foot state don't worry about it for
real it's just money
he couldn't even gambling no more huh
you know doing drugs no I just fell off
it are doing this again
and he goes down don't worry about I
don't worry about don't worry about it
and um I feel like giving him the money
now that I have it you know but I tried
giving it to him one time and he has
done don't worry about it
so I don't know what to do so yeah man I
I feel like [ __ ] bro like that I went
throw that money like what do you do
well can you do I was probably all the
money that he was saving her from all
the Slurpees and skittles when you were
a kid
I know man sometimes bro when I was the
one I was like on cocaine and sad I
would never
that would be like my the moment that I
would start crying it'll hit you yeah
cuz I had money
saved up from working with Gabri glasses
you know that went through all that
money bro
that's where I fell off when you're
[ __ ] around yeah bro we'll go over
there and pick up money brought in never
do you feel that way there do you feel
like regret somewhere in your life like
this like you need to apologize to
somebody
oh I tons of people his fight we go
through so many we use people a lot huh
I remember my dad one time when I was I
was working with him and there was a
gonna be you know I was I was doing a
little bit of comedy when I was younger
in New York he there was a comedian was
gonna be at some special dinner and he
got me we went together and before the
dinner I drank a lot of alcohol so I got
really messed up and then I think I
smoked some weed and then I just left
without telling my dad and I went to I
was staying with a girl I went to her
house I didn't even tell my dad went to
her house and my dad called me later
goes what the hell were you I go but
years later it hit me and I called him
up and I was bawling because I felt so
bad what I did to I could cry right now
and he didn't even remember it he didn't
remember it because I don't remember it
you know but it was just like I just but
I thought my dad he takes me to to a
dinner where the comedian cuz I'm doing
trying to get in a comedy they showed me
a professional comedian and I get drunk
and leave him there without even saying
goodbye
far without even saying goodbye when I
would say dad I don't feel good I'm
[ __ ] up I just leave [ __ ] him I mean
what was I thinking you know it just you
know IIIi called him up because he said
it was in Jersey at the time that I was
out here and I was just dad I guys
apologize for just remember this okay
clean up my yeah man um I remember when
um we had a birthday party for my son
and I had like um I had saved up money
for us to buy um [ __ ] but then I saw my
father there and I started give me the
money
no no no no no I'm probably was no no
you have a nice place you know whatever
anyone taking so but yeah man just
knowing you know like
I felt good that I came clean right now
but yeah man it's been bugging me for
years bro but I did apologize but just
to just knowing man just a feeling of
knowing that you're gonna come clean
like I was trying to avoid you the whole
time like a return phone call you know
I'm busy
then finally I was cornered him money
than a [ __ ] loan shark but you can
look at it now it's like yeah you you
you blew that money whatever but he
can't it's like a gift he gave you yeah
he doesn't want you to pay it back so
it's like he's your dad he gave you a
gift so it's off you're all square yeah
[ __ ] I mean dude all that other [ __ ]
is different dog what bothers you more
you know me doesn't bother them maybe
you have some [ __ ] around money for em
too and now I know I'm doing about the
specials couldn't coming out I took a
lot of [ __ ] about him now email or a
play but they could find your podcast
I'll Berman you could find out I'd
iTunes if you got the the the Apple
products be on by the way you know I
never have kiss but I would love to
bring you an addiction yeah absolutely
man cuz usually I just do the stories
but I'd love to have you on man your
website as well right that's right sober
man podcast calm or Albert man calm and
in stitcher and Google music if you got
the Droid yes coming up and support at
support it sober man podcast calm you
want to write to me nothing to report
now I'm just sort of getting my toe back
into the stand-up thing so what brought
you out to the to the west coast dude
I'm curious I always wanted to come out
here to LA and I had a friend of mine it
was doing a tour trying to get become an
actor so we were super young were you
attracted by television to come on here
because my wife she loved California
like when she was here that the breeze
company oh yeah television oh yeah this
was the the I used to call up remember
for the old you would call up the
operators and that back in when I was a
kid it didn't cost any money I would
call LA and ask for like phone numbers
of movie stars like I would call up and
go kay I like the number of Tony Curtis
and then they go you know cuz he was a
big star in in any hope then I would I
knew his real name was Bernard Schwartz
how about Bernard Schwartz
we have 27 Bernard Schwartz is here in
Beverly Hills alone you know and the
punk bands that you played with what
were those back in the day I mean well
about we didn't REM was not a punk band
but because they you should take of the
Minutemen on the road right yeah yeah
but the REM was one of the guys who came
in jam with us we we ran a French label
and we weird with the replacements and
oh okay Gramps oh really no and and the
drummer from X used to come see us all
that you don't like the blasters and all
that team I didn't know that well not
too much okay oh not too I knew the
drummer from the X better Alice bar and
Downton I never did Alice bar
no that was it rigid or punk big no I
did it yeah I did all the guessing the
80s Alice bar was the place to be for
punk
I did the Madame Wong's Madame Madame's
want Madame Wong's West the club
lingerie which i think is fun
where's it go the VEX and then the the
drummer from ex is DJ Bonebrake gorgeous
ombre Gorky Park with a club to write
gorky's I think Corky's me on Cahuenga
Boulevard yeah that was that was when I
first got sober that was a place to go
to eat at night well yeah it's a place I
don't know maybe they might have
Jericho's led to the remember that the
little bar that little cafe these two
open 24 hours on Alameda atomic cafe
oh yeah that's near my house yeah yeah
yeah old school was so full podcast with
Rogelio Torres once you Instagram or
Twitter Alberto my Instagram oh my my my
twitter is at al Berman comic and my
Instagram I can't remember sober man
podcasts write sober sober man podcast
yes sir and fully and you have the yeah
man right yeah man right thank you
everybody for listening thank you man
picture
want to get the middle
[Music]